saporizia bis vor einem halben Jahr
dürften die wenigsten bei uns diesen Ort
in der Ukraine gekannt haben obwohl dort
das größte Atomkraftwerk Europas steht
seit dem russischen Überfall auf die
Ukraine ist dieses AKW unter russischer
Kontrolle und das kann einem Angst
machen auch vor einem neuen gennobel
immerhin nach einigen Schikanen haben
Inspekteure der Internationalen
Atomenergieorganisation saporizia heute
erreicht
[Musik]
endlich die Beobachtermission der
internationalen Atombehörde ist im
umkämpften Atomkraftwerk saporiza im
Süden der Ukraine eingetroffen nach
langem diplomatischen hin und her
zwischen Russen und Ukrainern gelingt es
den atomkontrolleuren schließlich das
Gelände von Europas größtem
Kernkraftwerk mitten im Kriegsgebiet zu
erreichen lange Zeit schien es so als
wollte Putin die atompolizei vom
Kraftwerk fernhalten nun also die Wände
Rückblick am 4 März 2022 kommt es zu
ersten Kämpfen um das ukrainische
superkernkraftwerk saporica Feuer bricht
aus
das Feuer ist eine Folge von Schüssen
auf das Kernkraftwerk ich wiederhole das
Feuer hat infolge der Angriffe durch
Kräfte der Russischen Föderation auf das
Kernkraftwerk begonnen
die Lage ist unübersichtlich bedrohlich
nicht nur für die Ukraine sondern für
ganz Europa droht uns ein neues
Tschernobyl Politiker auf der ganzen
Welt zeigen sich besorgt allgemein
ich bin nach wie vor zutiefst besorgt
über die Entwicklung der Situation in
und um Europas größtes Kernkraftwerk in
saporicja plant
immer wieder kommt es in der Folge rund
um den Atommeiler zu militärischen
Vorfällen Teile des Kraftwerks werden
abgeschaltet vergangene Woche
schließlich bricht ein Team der
internationalen Atomenergieorganisation
von Wien aus in Richtung Ukraine
die Situation im Kraftwerk und in enabu
da und Umgebung bleibt äußerst
gefährlich die Besatzer verlassen die
Stationen nicht setzen ihren Beschuss
fort und entfernen ihre Waffen und
Munition nicht aus der Station sie
schüchtern unser Servicepersonal ein das
Risiko einer nuklearen Katastrophe wird
von Stunde zu Stunde größer
die Ukrainer indes bereiten sich auf den
Gau den größten anzunehmenden Unfall vor
Retter in Schutzanzügen Autos die
gewaschen und Menschen die auf eine
mögliche Kontamination untersucht werden
die ukrainischen Behörden ordnen eine
strahlungsnotfallübung an
trotz allgemeiner Warnungen will der
Chef der internationalen Atombehörde
seine Mission nicht abbrechen am
Mittwoch schließlich bricht das Team der
IAEA von Kiew tiefer in das Kriegsgebiet
in Richtung saporica auf
genauing nach sechs Monaten intensiver
Bemühungen geht es nun endlich los die
Internationale
Atomenergieorganisation wird das
Kernkraftwerk saporizia besuchen wie Sie
wissen haben wir dort eine sehr wichtige
Aufgabe zu erfüllen die tatsächlich Lage
dort einzuschätzen und so weit wie
möglich zur Stabilisierung der Lage
beizutragen
doch das Team erreicht das Kraftwerk
zunächst nicht die vorher festgelegte
Route wird heftig beschossen an einem
russischen Kontrollpunkt in der Stadt
war sie lief gar werden die Experten
zunächst aufgehalten können aber
schließlich weiterfahren
währenddessen verkündet der Sprecher des
russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums das
ukrainische Einheiten versucht haben
sollen das Kernkraftwerk zurückzuerobern
heftige Feuergefechte und zerstörte
Häuser in unmittelbarer Umgebung des
größten Atomkraftwerks Europas mitten in
einem tobenden Krieg
nun hat das Team der internationalen
Atomenergieorganisation nach Angaben
internationaler Presseagenturen das
Kraftwerk endlich erreicht
über die Lage vor Ort ist bisher nichts
bekannt offenbar ist ein Reaktor nach
wie vor in Betrieb eine tickende
Zeitbombe
das alles nach über sechs Monaten Krieg
inzwischen in der Ukraine
[Musik]